have the sexual liberations of [ __ ]
whoever they want sorry
the woman has to worry about the
repercussions of having sex with her
whoever she wants whatever she like has
a child because of that like she just
wanted to go out and have sex and have
fun because those consequences about the
man can not in her and then just
wait he could be on child support for 18
years there are men that have committed
suicide over the amount of child support
that they pay they're financially
incentivized in court to overestimate
the cost that it takes to raise a child
so that they can hook men on child
support they actively had sex with them
I'm not talking about like long-term
things I'm talking about like hook up
situations like they actively if they're
having sex with her and like you you
like [ __ ] in her and you actively did
that and she has to go the next morning
get the morning after pill or if she's
too late for that she has to get the
abortion maybe you don't know him like
what repercussions does he okay but she
she gets that she gets that choice men
if they if they're both doing the same
thing right they're both irresponsible
in the situation so the woman gets to
have the freedom to get the plan b or be
abortion he has no choice like if he got
her pregnant he doesn't believe in
abortion what choice does he have none
if she wants to put him on child support
what choice does he have now
she has to live with those consequences
so she has to get pregnant she has to
know she could give it up for adoption
my mom got pregnant at 17 she gave the
kid the process of getting pregnant
yeah it can be quite a strain in your
psychology but then you can get an
abortion even that is
loads of people say
apology you can't
sorry I was just saying that as a
comeback to like you were all saying
like just be celibate then but like what
if you do just want to like go out and
have sex with you then you have to deal
with the consequences you can do that I
say fine but if you're gonna do that I
would say get an IUD because
the contraceptive falls on the woman
yeah
she's the one that has to give birth and
stuff and she has to deal with like
being pregnant but why does
contraception have to fall on her when
all these contraceptive methods most
likely lately cause like hormonal
imbalances and they have side effects on
her whereas the man most men are more
likely to look for one like one night
stands and stuff and they can just go
and [ __ ] this girl and then he doesn't
have to do one of the three men or
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year under 30. so it's not and
women are having more sex than men yeah
and even male contraception that has
been trialled has had side effects of
female contraception no so the issue
like a lot of times they say that but
that's not
they were sterilized from it and I think
one or two guys died so it was a pretty
you know yeah but also death is a side
effect of some contraceptions they do
say it goes right in the side effects
they couldn't yes right but but I think
it was like a sample of a thousand
um roughly or maybe it was a thousand or
less I if I'm it's off the top of my
head but it wasn't a big sample size so
if you're taking birth control and you
knew it was one out of a thousand you
probably I wouldn't do it but it is true
why do women have to take responsibility
okay okay let's let's go from the
beginning every every step of the way
women have Choice men don't okay so let
me let me just I know I know okay wait
please let me let me finish this and
I'll explain so if we both want to have
sex after the sex men lose the choice
because women have the choice to be on
birth control actually before even
before women have the choice to be on
birth control or not that's our choice
right we have the choice to track when
we're ovulating we know when we're
ovulating they don't that's a choice
right we have the choice to go get the
plan B he can't make you take it that's
a choice we have the choice to say hey
if outside of essay I don't have sex
without condoms that's a choice then if
I if I get pregnant you can get an
abortion that's a choice
him being on child support for 18 years
no choice
no choice he goes to jail if he doesn't
pay it here I think they seize your
assets in the U.S they go to jail
[Music]
it's Peak but
I just say just be selective I'm not
gonna lie I'm not on any birth control
why because I'm selective and I'm
careful and I'm not out there like that
do you see what I mean I'm natural and
I'm not going to put things in my body
that going to ruin me so I'm taking the
responsibility for the situation I put
myself in and I'm not doing the things
that are going to put me at risk it's
really that simple you just got to make
better decisions for yourself and we
need to stop talking about oh men and
women make bad decisions for yourself
men make better decisions maybe pick
better women women that seem to be maybe
a little bit more mentally stable don't
just go off of what I've heard the West
is great or not the West that the East
is great I remember the past four I've
heard great things about Brazil for the
guys be careful well actually let me
know because I'll get canceled all men
have to do is just wrap it up though
simple
I hear stories and I'm like oh wow then
but but like the whole point is that we
have more choice in it so it comes with
being more responsible but you don't you
don't even have to pay for Condoms all
you have to do is go to your doctor go
to your sexual health clinic whether you
are a woman or a man you can go to your
clinic and saying I need some supplies
they will give you a nice little paper
bag yes I've had that before and they
will give that to you whether you are a
man or a woman so there's no excuses
even as a woman if you don't want to
take the pill and you want to use a
condom
yeah to have some have supplies for free
yeah I think I didn't I don't know what
you're saying sorry because I know
there's different
certain women don't like having rubber
um
downstairs and stuff right with the
condom situation I get that but I feel
like
a lot of these decisions that we've been
discussing is just being a short-term
interaction with a long-term consequence
that a lot of people don't want to take
accountability for
how about investing if you if you're not
comfortable with the idea of celibacy or
or having sex to procreate
investing more time and educating
yourself in ways to naturally
um I guess um reduce the the possibility
of having a child you know as you're
saying about cycles for example or men
training themselves to to to uh to pull
out or you know I mean um retention all
these kind of things
pre-comm you know what I'm saying like
there's there are things that you can do
before you have that interaction and and
risk it to I mean risk it long term I
mean and I don't think there's enough of
a conversation around different
exercises you can do to basically
self-con um
basically natural contraception
techniques or falling in women's yeah
cycle for example and you can only get
pregnant like three to five roughly
exactly yeah yeah yeah and more often
than not I could be wrong but do correct
me women but like
my understanding is from my experience
I've when women have been more attracted
to me I've been when they've been more
more fertile yeah there is first thing
but yeah so chances are more of it falls
on you women because you know when
you're fertile we don't so it's like
when you're having these fertile
experiences you're increasing the
likelihood of even having a child so why
not just get accustomed to having
sex when you're not fertile and reducing
that that possibility that rather than
just saying you're not it's less
enjoyable when you're not far tired
enjoyment
yeah it's like it's like you guys want
to do whatever you want and have no
responsibility yeah it's the same thing
if we're gonna have all the
responsibility I'd have all the
responses
the artificial woman to my body so it's
now my fault
that's the part I'm a bit confused
guys guys it has to be one at a time so
most of the girls I've been with outside
of my relationship they have insisted I
wear a condom so it's like this inequity
you're talking about options isn't it
like doesn't a condom solve it like a
guy yeah yeah a fair enough condom
solves it but with like some guys don't
want to wear a condom to be honestly
don't have sex with them
simple some women a lot of women don't
actually want condoms as well don't they
don't want guys wearing a condom so it's
a thing where like if you're concerned
about this and you know when you're
fertile I promise you right yeah if you
tell a guy I am very fertile and I'm
very likely to be pregnant over the next
week
he will he will himself come forward and
say I will be the contraception I will
be celibate I promise you it sounds
funny but if you as women I should tell
men when you're fertile because a guy it
doesn't matter it's a day John Lane if
it means that like that 18 years and
wait in five days and we still get to do
what we've got to do
it's it's logical you know my point
isn't that men have no responsibility I
I don't think it's wise to shoot up at
random girls that you don't know I don't
think that's smart
but but the point is that like we have
10 choices they have one maybe now
actually if we're gonna count 41 forms
of birth control we probably have like
50 choices and they have they have like
a vasectomy and condoms that's it why do
we make more forms for men
I think I think there's either there's
either two theories as to why there's no
birth control for men
um one is that women don't want to give
up power
and that too is that it's harder
biologically like scientists can't
figure out a way I do not believe that
you can create semen men can create
semen throughout their whole life women
can make what you are born with the
amount of energy right now women have a
hundred percent of reproductive power
over who was born a hundred percent
women are in complete control even the
odds so I I agree I think there should
be a male birth control yeah but it's
it's the fact that our society isn't
isn't putting money into that our
society doesn't focused on that because
apparently we don't have to deal thank
you it's patriarchal think like women
have to deal with all this
responsibility well is that patriarchal
when women make 70 to 80 of consumer
buying decisions women women have more
power than men I would argue because
we're the ones bailed out of every bad
decision I would say as well actually as
women the you know we are the ones that
get pregnant we are the ones that will
grow the baby inside of us and therefore
I believe that actually if you are going
to put yourself in that situation you do
have to take
um account of that that power that you
do have to bring life into this because
the man cannot so he will never
understand what it means so he'll just
do anything willy-nilly doesn't think
about the consequences as deep because
it's not going to go inside of him I I
asked one of my friends I said to him oh
he just had a baby I said yo bro how'd
you feel you had a baby did you cry he
said actually no I don't know how I felt
because the baby was inside my girl for
all these months she's had a head start
on knowing the child or it's because she
is the woman she has the baby I just
added to it so I didn't really think
about what it felt because I still had
to get to know the baby simply for the
fact that it is us so I would say for
sure I me as a woman I take
responsibility if I was to get pregnant
right now I would not go in I didn't
want the baby I want to go to my man and
do whatever man come in front be like yo
listen I'm pregnant what we gonna do
I'll be like okay I made a mistake I
[ __ ] up what am I gonna do that's it
so you if you don't want to be in that
situation just put that where am I going
to do before the mistake even happens
because you're gonna be the one with the
baby if we talk about the fact that the
women is the usually the one that stays
with the child because we're more
nurturing then again it just goes the
parents don't give it to men that's it
so you actually as a woman now in that
situation understand your power actually
as when we have a lot of power the only
part the only problem with us is that we
make the wrong choices that's it we only
realize the power that we have when
we're using it for the wrong reasons or
when we have lost it when we've made
mistakes that's instrumental you said we
we have we make the wrong choices
yeah I would say so yes
what happened to you every time I talk
on this podcast yeah I talk from
experience because I know that not only
the choices I've made the choices a lot
of my friends have made I also talk
about men because I also see a lot of
the mistakes they've made but when it
comes to this when it comes to this sort
of situation I know the power that I
have and I know the responsibility that
I have I will not run away from it to
say all equality because this is one of
those one things actually that is not
equal between women and men at all a man
cannot give birth to a child we can that
is completely different so we have that
power we need to take responsibility for
it I would I want to add for men as well
watching this
just download one of those free apps
like be around like download one of
those three apps use a rubber as long as
you can until you figure out her cycle
it tell you or tell you when she's like
pretty much when she's fertile
make sure that you've got a rubber on if
you want to be active then
and outside of that there's you know
there's ways to work around this
naturally you might even do both job
section ship contraception like on a
pill or whatever and condoms if you want
to be ultra safe yeah that's it I mean
it's it's there's enough out there's
more than enough out there but
communication everyone's saying you know
like why isn't there more there's like
the the stuff that is that's already out
there
people are only using probably three out
of the how many 40 something options you
know so I feel like it really it really
falls back on the internet option three
for men track your girl's cycle
the guys literally that I did that
myself and it's a thing where I I went
natural I mean I wasn't into
um until that's um you know the the
actual you have to take risks so you
like to take risks not necessarily it's
calculated calculated calculated risk
calculated executions but I'm just
saying that ultimately I didn't know the
day there's nature app playing and if
you actually understand nature for it is
as you're saying as you know the whole
fertility thing is a couple of days in a
month right if is that correct yeah
so if you've got three to five days in a
month right you've got about 30 days in
a month right yeah the nasty and not
have consequences sorry to do the nasty
and I have questions
like this he's in a relationship clearly
no I'm not in a relationship but the
point I'm making is that three two four
wait is it three to five days right
let's let's call it five let's call it a
week let's call it a week right yeah you
have to spoken to her a lot yeah but
what I'm saying is that let's call it a
week here yeah let's call it a week
right yeah and you've got three other
weeks in the month right yeah and one of
them you're extremely if you're both
aware of when that first when that
fertile for me it doesn't make sense why
why you wouldn't want to know when when
you when your woman when you if you
don't want to be a parent it doesn't
make sense to me why you wouldn't want
to know
when when your partner's fertile because
as a woman that's the highest that's
literally the most certain time that you
can get pregnant right so if you're not
taking accountability for that I'm sorry
but I feel like more that percentage
falls on you and as a man You're Not
Innocent in this because that is
something that you can learn I
understand that women are when they they
sh there aren't other women it it moves
a couple days here and now I get that
but ultimately just find out when her
time of the month is what's the app
called
obviously that would work in a situation
um in a relationship what would you say
to the people who want to have one night
stands and you can't really I want to
say you can't have that conversation up
front but it's like
condoms yeah
especially especially for a one-night
stand you've got to wrap it up like
literally you you're you're welcome
[Applause]
I can't even say that word now exactly
what I said I'm going to coin that
phrase I'm gonna I'm gonna copyright it
padlock your pants
padlock your pants make that go viral
padlock your pants okay I'm gonna as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible